Evet
Ee herkese Merhaba ismim Pınar'ın o kalp
bugün vurdu olduğu için ben de çok
mutluyum herkes gibi
ben yaklaşık
20 yıldır Özel sektörde gıda
kategorisinde çalışıyorum la Yani
bir yöneticiyim bu sektörde kapitalizmin
içerisinde
bugün bu görüşmeye toplantıya konuşmaya
gelirken birçok şey düşündüm Aslında
neler neler söyleyebilirim insana dair
kadına dair bedenime dair sistemin
içindeki yerime dair diye ve böyle
spontan bir ve konuşma yapmak istedim
insanı anlamak
benim hayatım boyunca çok önemli bir şey
oldu
insan çok katmanlı bir varlık Sistemler
çok katmanlı hatta bizim şu anda bir
maneti izlediğimiz belki
ekip pozitif bilimlerden biraz daha
farklı olarak Hani felsefenin psikoloji
biliminin
farklı farklı alanların sanatın tarihini
içine girdiği bir açıklama katmanı
biçimi var denizi var E ben bunların
içerisinde kendimle ilgili ve
geleceğimle ilgili Bu sistemin içerisine
ne üretiyorum ne yapıyorum
bedenim niye var mesela pandemi den
sonra bedenime bu kadar ihtiyacım yoktu
Aslında evden çalışıyordum Ne oldu Ne
değişti
bedenimin sistemin kendi kendisini
üretme içerisindeki
ama nasıl şekilleniyor neden var neden
var olması isteniyor gibi soruları
kendimce cevaplamaya çalıştım
aradım Yani bunun anlamını
ve bir akış gördüm birazcık ondan
bahsetmek istiyorum
sistemi öyle bir şey ki bu biraz böyle
iktidarın üzerinde bir kavram daha geniş
bir kavram
benimse içinde bulunduğum sistem
Kapitalizm ya kimisine göre bu sistem
işte deji'den uza göre bir Makina işte
fıkraya göre iktidar ama sonuçta bana
göre Kapitalizm yani Kapitalizm benim
Makina makinam benden üretmeye çalışıyor
Ne yapıyor neden beni üretmeye çalışıyor
ve ilerde Ne olacak
şimdi bunları düşünürken Tabii ki ister
istemez geçmişte ne olduğunu da anlamaya
çalışıyorsunuz mesela feodal dönemde Sen
bedenim L E bedeniyle insanın iktidar
arasındaki
bağlantı ne mesaj Kaç çeşit insan bedeni
var Örneğin Şövalyeler Eğer iktidarın
bir temsilcisi olan Kral için ölmeye
razı bedenine bu şekilde kullanmaya razı
Beki Başka ne var ne çeşit bedenler var
sistemin ürettiği
yani tarım için gıda için yiyecek için
yiyecek üreten bedenler var
mesela ağırlıklı olarak da kadınlar peki
başka ne var Şu Kralı koruyan Şövalye
hizmet eden Parkı
köleler var
yani işte tarım üretiminin veya gıda
üretimini yemek üretimini içinde olmayan
ama farklı görevleri olan ki Ne var peki
sonra ne oluyor yani Binbir açıdan
değerlendirilmiş endüstriyel Devrim işte
İngiltere'de başlayan makinaların doğuşu
Sanayi devrimiyle ne oluyor bu bedenlere
ihtiyaç bir miktar azalıyor mesela
Makina beden değilim tarım
Sağol olarak üretime katkı yapan
makineler devreye girdikten sonra ne
oluyor derseniz Tabiki bedene olan
ihtiyaç yazılıyor ve orada bir miktar
insan
dışarıya kayıyor Ne yapıyor peki bu
insanlar yani
tarımsal üretimde bir Makina Örneğin
Hadi atarım da demeyin bir makine örneği
bir metre kumaş yerine 50 metre kumaş
üretebiliyor sana orada artık yüz insana
çalışmasına gerek var mı yok pek ne
yapsın Bu insanlar bu bedenler nereye
gitsin bu bedenlerin biri mesela sanatçı
olsun işte bir bilim adı bu
ve tüketsin Niye Çünkü üretim var
öğretmek zenginlik demek peki
kapitalizmde ne var bu var ve ki
kapitalizmde vadediyor ileri gitmeyi
ibadet diyor beden için bizim için biz
ileriye gitmek zorundayız ve hep böyle
yaşadık yani 14'üncü Yüzyıldan sonra ora
hep şöyle zannediyoruz Yani eskiden de
herkes İleri gitmek istiyordu Aslında
böyle bir şey yok yani Eskiden 14.
Yüzyılda ki bir insan için Kapitalizm
sistemi içerisinde oluşan varlığımızın
düşüncelerimizin anlamamızı aynı şekilde
olduğunu düşünmek çok yanlış o zaman ki
insan bin yıl önce ataları nasıl
yaşıyorsa ve o da öyle yaşayacak diye
düşünüyor yani ya Şövalye olacak yak
öyle olacak ya işte tarımda makine
olacak ya makine beden alacak salak Peki
şimdi ne oldu şimdi İnsan değişik bir
evreye bu mesela ben bunu çevremde o
kadar çok görüyorum ki arkadaşlarım da
diğer yönetici Arkadaşlarımla birlikte
çalıştığım insanlarla bütün Network'ün
içerisinde Herkes bu anlamı sorguluyor
ya benim burada ne yapıyorum ya ben yani
Ben ileriye gitmesem ne olur mesela
ileriye gitmesem Etkin olmasam kârlılık
üretme Sen büyüme üretme Sem ne olur
Kim bu değişik bir soru yani bu o kadar
yaygın bir konu ki şu anda e bak pandemi
Dede Ben bunun bir örneğini gördüm bir
laptopla biraz filmde biraz kitapla
internette yaşayabiliyorum benim bedenim
biraz Özgür artık yani bedenimin İlla
bir yerlerde olması gerekmiyor ya ne
için yaşıyorum yani Cep telefonu için
yaşıyorum yani Hani eskiden Vay Çok yaşa
kral ındıo ölme Cindy en büyük suçun ölü
müydü E şimdi ne peki
sistemin ölümü en büyük suç peki var
yani sistem mi sistem ama sana bir
taraftan da şunu söylüyor yani bizim
yaşadığımız şey bu aslında
bir yandan
iklimsel olarak geri dönüşü olmayan bir
yola Girdik Bir yandan çok büyük bir
üretim patlamasının çağının ucuna geldik
sonuna geldik ve sadece bir iki Yüzyıl
kadar insan aslında bu bolluğu yaşadık
yani onun dışında yaşamı hep kıyılar
daydı Yani az yemekle büyük bir yaşam
mücadelesi veriyordu Şimdi biz bunu tam
olarak anlayamadık yani tam olarak bunu
yaşayamadık
Geldiğimiz noktada
bedenlerimize ihtiyacımızın ya sistemi
bizim bedenimize olan ihtiyacının da
oldukça azaldığını fark etmeye
başlıyoruz
yani işte İngiltere'de makine çıkıyor
işte hemen sevginizin doğuyor
iki tane Çünkü bedenler özgürleşiyor Ben
artık bir kadın olarak veya insan olarak
bedenim hakkında kendi hükmün var
başkasının Yani bir korsanı gelip beni
kaçırıp bir yere götür köle yapması
mümkün değil ben ister evlenirim ister
evlenmem ister çocuk doğru ister
doğurmam istediğin şey yapabilirim
bedeninde bu sistemde bunu karşı özgürüm
Hatta bunu
yani jenerasyon farklı ile birlikte de
yaşıyoruz mesajla kuşa bu bağlantıyı bu
kendi kendine yaşamasını Özgür kendini
ki halini Eğer ailesiyle yaşıyorsa bir
çatışma içinde de yaşayabiliyor ya onlar
için ileriye gitme kavramı çok
önemliyken bu yeni nesil için yeni dünya
için üretimin artık sonuna geldiği Çünkü
üretemediği çünkü üretirse yok olacağını
anladığı Dünya ile birlikte duvara
çarpacağını anladığı bir kağıda tüketme
Bu
bir varlık var yani tüketmek istemiyor
kendi halinde yaşamak istiyor anlamıyor
Eğer önce sanat sonra Nora sanatın bu
geriye dönüşü böyle zanaat e dönüşü işte
içimdeki o sıcaklığı Peki nasıl
Bulacağımı gidiyor ve bu platformun
üstüne nasıl çıkacağım benim bedenimin
sistem için anlamı ne benim için
anlamına bana neden ihtiyaç var bu
sistemde bunu anlamak çağımızın en ama
en önemli problemi şu anda Belki ben
bunu daha herkesten farklı hissediyor
Olabilir çünkü rekabetin ön sayfalarında
yarışıyorum Belki o yüzden bunu daha
şiddetli hissediyor olabilirim Ama şunu
biliyorum ki
ben aslında hiç ileriye gitmeden hiç
Etkin olmadan hiç
kârlılık diye şu anda Vur aşmadan kendi
halinde yaşayabilirim Asistan bana bunu
verebilir Niye Çünkü aslında bir yerde
bir örtüşme oldu bu kötü bir şey değil
yani bir yerde Yapay Zeka dediğimiz Hani
Tabii ki hani
birçok tartışma var Frankfurt Okulu ve
sahibinden Ben de inanmıyorum yani bir
insanı üretebileceği ne Yapay Zeka mı da
mı yapay zekayı şöyle görmek lazım yani
Yapay Zeka nasıl ki ilk devrimde makine
olduğu ve insan boşa çıktı farklı
mesleklere evrildi ve başka şeyler yaptı
ama şimdi gelen devrimle şimdi gelen
devrim Emek piyasasını Yani benim
bedenimi yerle bir edecek bir devrim
geliyor yani ne ne oluyor yani
bildiğiniz teşhis koyan doktor yok
bankada çalışan yok Eskisi gibi Çünkü
Yapay Zeka var insanlar şundan
bahsediyorlar yani günde
Gününüzün yüzde 60'ının bir yapay zeka
ile geçeceğine plana içeri bu sistem
yani artık Ben evimde oturacağım
laptobun maaş iki senede bir arabam
laptobun falan yenilenecek tos yerleşme
biçimi de birazcık oradan
tamamlayacağım ve bana işte evime hop
patates load edilecek hopçe gelecek
Karşılığında ne vereceğim sistemi
bedenimi istemiyor ne vereceğim yani
acaba özgürlüğümü vereceğim Her gün
gidip kalma aldıracağım mesela Biraz
ilerlesin diye ya bilimle Mesela bu
zaman içerisinde bayağı bir geri geldi
yani insanın anlam arayışına cevap
olamadı Mesela benim de bu Tabi şu
anlamda söylemiyor bilim her zaman lazım
ve bir şekilde de hayatımızın içinde çok
önemli bir yere sahip bunu küçümsemek
değil Amacım ama bilim Mino manipülatif
Dünyası ya çok spesifik bir konuyu
araştırarak ona katkı yapması bilim
adamlarının birçok topyekûn dev beğendi
süre içerisinde a Ben bunu kaybolmasına
sebep oldu Yani insanlar artık
post-truth denilen bir Çağa girdi ve bu
post-truth ne diyor ne söylüyor ya Nasıl
bir çabuk Bu
Algıladığı anlam kendisiyle ve sistemde
ve yapmak istediği şeylerle ilgili
komple değişti yepyeni bir dünyaya geçti
artık ilerlemek istemiyor artık kendine
dönmek istiyorum Ve Tanrı yerine veya
işte dinler yerine koyduğu samimiyet
iyilik ise içinde şimdi Bizim karşımızda
çevremize her gün duyduğunuz eminim
Sizlerde hepiniz duyuyorsunuz şöyle
insanlar var ya Ben artık Yani bunun
içinde olmak istemiyorum mn yapmak
istiyorsun kendimi yolculuğuna çıkmak
istiyorum güzel harika bir dünya yepyeni
din bu
ne yapacaksın kendi yolculuğuna Çıkıp
kendimi keşfedelim ne nasıl keşfedecek
sinch işte bu şimdilik anlarımda
kalacağım Peki ne bulacaksın Orada işte
o Buldum benim zaten o benim bulduğum
Tanrı ol samimiyet ol benim içimde bir
şey var ve ben onun yolculuğuna çıkmak
istiyorum Ha yemek yemek işte bir
şeylerle uğraşmak bir şeyler üretmek
onları da biraz yapay zekalar yapsın
işte insanlığın geldiği bilinç yapsın bu
bütün bu anlattığım şey yani Benim
bedenimin sistem içindeki yerine ne
olacağını belirleyen şeye biyopolitika
diyorlar Aslında ve ben kendi adıma şunu
gördüm ki Kapitalizm
Eskiden feodal sistemin Cevap verdiği
biyopolitika sorusuna henüz cevap
veremedi benim bedenimle ne yapacağına
karar vermiş değil Ve bunu bana
yansıtmış değil ben o yüzden bu dev
sistemde her ne kadar hani bilinç
felsefecileri Benim bilincim var elimi
kaldırmak istiyorum kaldırıyorum desede
bir kısmını ve bilinçli bir kısmı
Aslında bedenin konusunda bilinçsiz ya
onu yöneten bir sistem var Bir toplumun
geneli için düşünürsek şimdi
bizim Geldiğimiz noktada benim en
azından geldiğim noktada ben şunu
hissediyorum görüyorum anlam arayışı mı
yepyeni bir dinle
oturdum kendimi anlamak kendi
yolculuğuna çıkma kendi masalımı yaşamak
kendi hikayemi yaşamak Bunu bulurken de
olabildiğince bunu odaklanacak vakit
zaman yer alan açmak kendimi ve bunun
için çok şeye ihtiyacım yok yani şu anda
çok çalışıyorum ve çok tüketiyorum ama
çok yakında tüketmeye ceğim
ve çalışmak istemeyeceğim Peki o zaman
ne olacak bak ne olacak benim anlam
dünyanın içerisinde kendim varım sadece
yeni dinin bu Peki bunu ne ve endüstri
devriminden sonra oluşan Kapitalizm için
anlamı ne
ben bu soruyu çok merak ediyorum ve
çevremde de konuşuyorum ve araştırıyorum
okumaya devam ediyorum Ey sistem Sen el
makina zam benim bedenime ne yapmak
istiyorsun Bundan sonra
bu aslında bir taraftan da dünyanın
geldiği evre olarak düşündüğümüzde de
çok da böyle İnsan kendi doğasına çok
yaklaştığı bir yere gidiyor gibi
görünüyor Yani iklim krizinden dolayı
bir yere geliyor daha mikro yaşamlara
geçmesi gerekiyor daha Suk etmek zorunda
kalacağı kesin daha az çalışmak zorunda
kalacak bu sadece onu kararıyla ilgili
olmayacak makinalar onun rahatlıkla
yerine geçebilecek Çünkü şöyle düşünün
yani Eskiden
tarlada çalışan yüz kişiye ne bir makine
koyuyor ve onlar gidiyordu Başka işler
yapıyordu dediğim gibi bankacı oluyordu
vesaire ama şimdi Öyle değil Şimdi
şoförün yerine koyuyorsunuz makinayı
yapay zekayı e-şoför ne yapacak yani bu
araba daha mı ileriye gidecek daha ama
çok üretecek yani birşey yönetemeyecek
ki Ee yani ne yine daha verimli olacak
Hani bu hiç yaklaşıma gibi düşünün yani
kapitalizmin ana şeyi verimlilik üretim
zenginlik Peki ya Şu an ne olacak Yapay
Zeka gelince devir Emek piyasasından
çıkan ama böyle yani şeyi düşün tır
şoförleri işte uçak pilotları avukatlar
karar veren yargıçlar Bunlar yok olacak
ortadan ne yapacak bu İnsanlar fakir ya
Ne karşılığında yok olacak bedenleri Tıp
için o daha uzun yaşamak 90 yaşına kadar
yaşayan insan bu bedenle eğlen nasıl
anlam kuracak bu kuracak ve ki kurdu
bunu yani anlattığım şey oydu kendi
dinini buldu kendi dininin yarattı kendi
gerçeğini yerine getirme diyebildim
buldu ama sistemle bağlantısı sistem ve
bağlantısını Maalesef şu anda ben de
arıyorum Bu konuda yorum yapanları
okuyorum ben de bulabilmiş değilim ama
bakmaya çalıştığım şey şu Evet ben
kendimle ilgili inanışlarını değiştirdim
neden var olduğun konusunda tatlı bir
anlama vardım Ama sistem beni niye hala
tutuyor bari diyor Bunu anlayamadım
henüz O yüzden
kolayca bir şey sarılabilirim ama
bütün bu katman Denizi ve sonsuz
etkileşimi arasında işte dinler
psikoloji insanın varoluşu Ama buna
sığınıp hani tek bir cepheden Bunu
yorumlamakta
bana İyice bu için biraz daha farklı bir
katmanların tamamını anlayan biraz daha
hümanity XEi hizmet edecek şekilde hep
düşünmeye çalıştım doluysa Bugün de
karşınıza Bu konuyla Çıktım ben bir
kadın olarak özel sektörde uzun
yıllardır yöneticilik yapan ve bu
sistemde
kapitalizmin en ön cephelerinde çalışan
bir makinanın makinası olarak
şunu görüyorum ki henüz gelecek olan
sistem benim bedenimle ne yapacağını
bilmiyor
buluşmam bu kadar çok teşekkür ederim
Dinlediğiniz a